problem five use the expression below to
answer the question that follows okay
there's my expression and here's the
question that follows which of the
following is the best estimate of the
value of the expression above so when
they want best estimate this really just
saying look you don't have to do all of
the math just kind of just kind of round
out everything and try to figure out
what this is saying so if I wanted to
round this out at the 30 2629
I'd say that's approximately equal to 30
thousand times instead of 484 I'm gonna
say that's roughly equal to 500 and then
divide that by three hundred and six
thousand seven hundred fifty-one I'm
gonna say that's roughly equal to three
hundred three hundred thousand so the
first thing I want to do maybe I'll
divide the top and the bottom by 3 so
this 30,000 will become darker color
will become ten thousand and this
300,000 will become one hundred thousand
one hundred thousand and then I could
start canceling out zeros if I divide
the top and the bottom by ten thousand I
can essentially get rid of four zeros on
the top and the bottom so then I this
10,000 divided by 10,000 will just
become one a hundred thousand divided by
10,000 is just ten that just becomes ten
and then we're left with five hundred
divided by ten we could just cancel out
some more zeros can't divide the top of
the bottom by ten
you get a 1 in the bottom and you get a
50 on top so you could say this is
roughly equal to 50 and lucky for us
that's actually one of the choices
problem 6
use the diagram below to answer the
question that follows the measurement in
the diagram above are shown rounded to
the nearest whole number which of the
following is a possible value of a the
area of the rectangle so what they're
saying is that these numbers these
aren't the actual values if we were to
be precise about it they just rounded
them to the nearest whole number when
you just multiply these two things to
figure out the area you get an area of 8
inches or 8 square inches but when you
look at the choices I don't
three and eight square inches it seems
like it's either going to be it's either
going to be B or C and if you just if
you just look at these two numbers which
ones closer let's see eight two five
point five so eight minus five point
five that's what 8 minus 5 is 3 inches
so this is two and a half inches or two
and a half inches from this one and we
are three and a half inches from this
one so if I was stuck for time I would
go with this one
but just to verify that this definitely
could be an answer if these are rounded
to the nearest whole number then this
one could be as low as 1.5 inches right
if this if this dimension is actually
1.5 inches when they rounded it they
were made it to it couldn't have been
one point four nine because then they
rounded it down
similarly this could have been as low as
three point five when they rounded they
would have rounded it to four it could
have they couldn't have been three point
four nine because then they would have
rounded it down to three so if this
dimension was three point five and this
dimension is one point five what would
the area of been so three point five
times one point five see five times five
is 25
3 times 5 is 15 plus 2 is 17 put a zero
down 1 times 5 is 5 1 times 3 is 3 5 7
plus 5 is 12 and then you have one plus
one plus three is five you have two
numbers behind the decimal point five
point two five so the minimum possible
area for this rectangle is 5 point 2 5
that's the minimum so 5 point 5 is
definitely a valid answer so I'm gonna
stick with my answer B next problem
next problem all right
use the table below to answer the
questions the question that follows okay
they see they have a store different
stores discount for manufacturer's
recommended price okay there we go
so they're all discounting games
Samantha wants to buy two computer games
each of which has a manufacturer's
recommended price of $20 she checks four
different stores and find the prices of
the games discounted as shown in the
table above and which store will
Samantha be able to buy the games for
the least amount of money I make sense
you want to find the cheapest place so
this is four dollars off the price of
each game remember she's buying to the
manufactured price is 20 so she's gonna
pay four dollars off of twenty for each
game so she's gonna pay 16 plus 16 which
is equal to 32 that's at store number
one 30% discount on each game so 30%
discount so $20 times 30% discount is
0.3 so point so you can imagine 3 times
20 is 60 and then you put the decimal
sign it's going to be a $6 discount on
each game for this one so $6 discount
remember 30% of 20 is six dollars so $6
discount will be 14 dollars right 20
minus 6 for a game that she buys so this
she's gonna spend 28 dollars at store
number 2 and switch colors 1/3 off the
price of the two games well you know you
could immediately say that 1/3 is 33% so
that's a bigger discount and this one
you could do the math you'll figure out
you know instead of this being instead
of instead of just being $6 it'll be $6
and 66 cents and it's gonna be $13 and
something something plus $13 something
something and you're gonna get you're
gonna get something you know 27 dollars
and some change but you know that this
is a better deal in this one because
this is the same thing as 33% off which
is clearly better than 30% off and then
this North won by one game and get the
second at half price so here she's gonna
spend she's gonna spend $20 on the first
game and then the second one is going to
be half price so she's going to spend
she's going to spend a total of 30
dollars so the best deal is store number
three where it's gonna be it's gonna be
27 something dollars right I mean store
number two is definitely better than
store number four which is definitely
better than store number one and the
store number three is definitely better
than store number two
3% discount so I'm gonna go with store
number 3
next problem go to the next problem 8
use the procedure below to answer the
question that follows ok n is equal to
0.62 - ok 100 n is equal to 63 this
multiplied by 100 ok they're doing
they're trying to eliminate the
repeating decimals I get it
the procedure above shows how to convert
a repeating decimal to a fraction
alright
if 0.125 6 1 2 5 6 is a decimal with 4
repeating digits which of the following
represents this decimal as a fraction so
what you do we'll just do what the
procedure we did before and this might
bring you back memories from algebra
class or pre-algebra class forget when
you first learn it you say and or we can
just do exactly what they did there is
equal to zero point 1 2 5 6 1 2 1 2 5 6
and then we could multiply that and you
can even pattern match here you had two
digits repeating they multiplied it by
100 100 has two zeros here we have four
digits repeating so we're going to
multiply it by something with four zeros
so we'll have 1 1 2 3 4 there's our 4
zero so that's 10,000 n is going to be
equal to what well that's what's point
one of 10,000 it's 1,000 let's point O 2
of 10,000 I think you get the idea it is
2,000 sorry it's 200 so you get one
thousand two hundred fifty six point one
two five six one two five six it just
keeps repeating on and on and on you get
the idea we just multiplied this by
10,000 because that allowed us to bring
one whole repetition to the left of the
decimal you could verify it actually
let's multiply it out just to verify
that this actually works I have
multiplied one two five six one two five
six times
times 10,000 10,000 what you can do is
you can just multiply it by one so you
get one two five six one two five six
add four zeros one two three four and
then count how many decimal points you
have one two three four five six seven
eight one two three four five six seven
eight and we verify that it works now of
course I didn't multiply the entire
repeating part if it just kept repeating
then we'd have a one two five six and
then keep repeating so on and so forth
but you saw it worked in the pattern and
it works here so once we get that we're
just essentially want to subtract this
guy from this guy so we say minus n or
you could say this is equal to minus
point one two five six one two five six
and we are left with on this side what's
10,000 minus one
well that's 9999 is equal to well when
you multiply when you do the subtraction
this and this part are gonna cancel out
the decimal parts cancel out and you're
just left with one thousand two hundred
and fifty six so 9999 and remember
there's a coefficient that I don't want
to lose that is equal to 12 56 or if we
divide both sides by 9999 you get so n
is equal to 12 56 divided by 9999 and
that is one of our choices 12 56 divided
by 9990